jumping high is an important skill for a
lot of sports and in certain circles of
the internet it's even become its own
niche competition the standing vertical
is one of the critical tests at the NFL
Combine and has long been a gold
standard for assessing human leaping
ability so who jumps the highest you
might think a dunk legend like Michael
Jordan would own the vertical leap
record but the highest jumpers actually
aren't basketball players football
players actually have the highest
vertical jump in basketball yeah most
people would think well basketball guys
jump more so they have the highest but
you know football players are used to
starting from a static position which is
what a vertical jump is the NFL combines
top leaper Gerald sensabaugh once hit 46
inches and then there's the extra inch
higher that USC football player Josh
Emmitt or Beibei was once measured
jumping so what's the limit today we're
gonna look at why jumping from a
standstill to higher than 50 inches is
almost impossible the Box jump which has
been made popular in part by CrossFit
workouts has gone viral on the Internet
and it's easy to see why this is heaven
under who set the Guinness world record
for a standing box jump at 63 and a half
inches he set the record for single leg
jump - to find out what it takes I
trained with hunger learn how to cheat
the analogue vertical jump test perfect
there's another end and talk to the
scientist about why some people like
Evan Hunger can jump so much higher than
the rest of us his muscles are capable
of doing bigger portals in New York we
flew him out to San Francisco to show us
how he jumps so high so this is
ridiculous this is up to almost my chin
we're 60 inches right so this is 5 feet
60 inches yep that's insane and that's
three and a half inches shy of the world
record which you set that's correct
right ok so like how how I can't even
think about how to do this what do you
do mentally and physically to prepare
for and then actually execute a jump
like this
I will train jumps sporadically but not
very often but a lot of weight training
and usually just focus on the lower body
so I'll be squatting three times a week
and I said I get closer the squats
change in variation in reps and sets
they get heavier and less reps and like
making you a lot stronger for a one time
explosive movement right mentally I
think the mental game is just as hard as
the physical game but the problem is
like mentally you can't really prepare
too too much for it but I find what I'm
coming up to the box I try not to think
of anything Unger train for a year
before he set his record I didn't have
that kind of time but with his coaching
I got 234 heads then 38 inches that's a
bike and then 42 inches alright this is
30 inch box 3/4 inch plates we're at 42
inches high before I began to really
worry about cracking a shin Unger had me
jumping to 46 inches thing is I'm not
technically jumping back because
remember the NFL Combine record is also
46 inches and I'm nowhere near as
athletic as a pro football player now
there are lots of different kinds of
jumps there's running jumps
high jumps triple jumps but the standing
vertical jump is used in the NFL Combine
and by sports scientists because it's a
good measure of explosive power the Box
jump looks amazing but it's not just
pure vertical jumping it's actually a
complex move that builds on top of a
vertical jump by pulling your feet up
towards your hips interestingly about a
century ago there was an Olympic event
called the standing high jump and it was
pretty similar to box jumping this guy
American Ray Erie was the reigning
champion he once cleared a bar at 65
inches if he were alive today he'd
probably give Unger a run for the box
jump title but we wanted to know how
Unger might stack up against today's NFL
Combine jumpers so he and I both jumped
in front of a measuring tape watched him
rise as you can see he out jumped me by
a lot
it was hardly scientific but it looks
like he's cruising two nearly three feet
that's almost 90 centimeters here's the
thing exactly how high he jumped depends
on how you measure it you start from a
standstill with his feet flat on the
ground or the moment before takeoff when
he's on his tiptoes depending on your
form and how big your feet are the
difference could be 10 or more inches
either way it's a very impressive jump
like a look at this guy needing a
standing vertical John big oh my god
what a monster right that's spy Oh
mechanist pastéis de pinna and my
specialty is trying to understand the
mechanics oh ha a fleas jump are
actually pretty intuitive the way to get
the biggest possible height is to have a
big vertical velocity at the end of the
tables so how do you do that de pinna
says it's all about moving up as
powerfully as you can for as long as you
can before leaving the ground ok so you
would think that you would go and you
would crouch yourself bend your legs
grandma and be down there and then wait
and say ok let's go and then you you
sure must
to extend your legs as powerfully as you
can to get out from the ground the
problem with that is that when you're
down there waiting to start your jump
you're making a force that is submaximal
he's just needing to make the force that
you need to hold a downward position and
to be able to go upward you need to make
a fourth of this bigger than that
he says there's an even better way so
what you do is instead of starting at
the bottom you start standing up so
you're standing up and then you relax
your muscles completely so you your legs
turn basically into wet noodles right
and your gravity is pulling downwards so
you go down yes you're using your
muscles to slow down this downward
motion you're activating those muscles
you're pre tensing the muscles so at the
very bottom point you have all of your
vertical range of motion for the upward
motion available to you still any
muscles are already pre tense it's
called the counter movement jump under
and I both tried it and not surprisingly
he jumped way higher than me I asked dr.
de pinna why he has better muscles his
muscles are capable of doing bigger
forces in New York basically this means
that he has a bigger cross-sectional
area of muscle and the main movers
really we're talking quads and glutes if
anyone knows how lucrative a solid jump
is it's Joel Smith he's a coach who runs
an online jumping Academy for athletes
who want to improve their leaping
abilities he watched me jump and offered
some suggestions for how to improve we
all know squats deadlifts front squat we
think strong legs it'll help I view it
as a way to create tension so right now
if we can create more tension in your
legs by getting stronger you will have
the capability to jump higher so it is
possible that I could get better at
jumping but I'll probably never get too
Unger's level that doesn't mean I
couldn't have a higher vertical jump I
went to sparta science to talk with
founder Phil Wagner from a research
standpoint vertical jump has been
associated with performance in a variety
of sports he works with pro athletes
including NFL hopefuls to post their
best vertical leap on an analogue
measuring device called a vertex using
it is simple just subtract the highest
you can reach while standing
from the highest you can reach while
jumping the difference is the height of
your jump kind of because for as easy as
the vertex is to use it's also really
easy to cheat just make your standing
reach as low as possible because you've
had a lot of elbow damage right right
Wagner showed me how I could add a few
inches with a fake injury
Wow you can't even get close let me walk
through this thing actually with my
short of my shoulder tipped up yep my
fingers extended my arm all the way
straight and they walks through again no
fake injury fully stretched out yeah
look at the difference that 45 seems a
lot closer now then I jumped right and
jumped again this time using another
trick some toe bounce which amplifies
the counter movements later it is yep
okay so how did I do
so what's considered probably average
quote-unquote average for an NFL vert
would be in the mid 30s about 35 so you
did about a 33 inch purchase there no
warmup
a little cheating no warmup the schedule
but here's the other thing scientists
can't even agree on the best way to
measure vertical jumps there's the
analog Burrtec there's video analysis
and then there's forceplates which
measure an athlete's force on the ground
to calculate the height of their jump
they're harder to cheat
they're also at Wagner's company uses
and thanks to their proprietary
equipment he says they're also far more
accurate at measuring a vertical leap
so fourteen point one inches that's half
first jump
that's half yeah after three average
jumps the force plate brought me back
down to earth and more than halved my
vertical leap to wait for it fifteen
inches is actually not a bad score it's
real now that might sound like a big
difference but remember the vertex isn't
very precise you can cheat it with the
arm extension trick and it's measuring
your jump from a flat-footed start even
though your body is fully extended at
the peak of your jump the force plate
just uses the speed you leave the ground
to determine your jump height Wagner
says the highest any athlete has
achieved on the Sparta plate that
includes pros he can't talk about it's
about 30 inches but he doesn't think
worth the limit just yet I believe that
we're capable of getting up on this you
know to a 40 inch vertical jump really
yes I know that song right now is 30 is
about 29 30 that's correct it's a fight
between gravity and muscle drop some
weight and you might float a bit higher
if I lose 10 pounds making a jump higher
yes as long as you don't lose the
capability making force with it's in
proportion so it counts as the ratio
before she can make on the ground or
muscle tension that you can make divided
by body weight or body mass so the
ratios for counts so if you can make
your body mass be one half which is
impossible or imagine if you make it be
one half that'll be amazing the problem
innocent to get the booty for force it's
also one half of the ones before you
have the same Wagner says better
nutrition careful training and injury
prevention could see athletes cruising
even higher I think the true limiting
factor is how well can we allow
individuals to recover and that's why
monitoring is so important I how do we
can do to add capacity on each of vigil
without having a setback
so it's possible we'll see somebody with
a greater vertical leap someday but for
now bear in mind that what some of these
athletes are doing is already almost
impossible
[Music]